À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Ah,
l'épopée temporelle continue.
Nos héros sont toujours
à la recherche du Docteur Simon,
le père d'Iris.
Nous les avions laissés
dans un bateau en feu
au large de l'île de la Réunion
en l'an 1710,
prêts à se faire découper
par la Buse,
le célèbre pirate sanguinaire.
Après tout, il a une hache,
il faut bien qu'il s'en serve.
Mais pourquoi
vous voulez nous tuer ?
On se connaît même pas.
Moi, les gens,
c'est pas compliqué.
Soit ils me donnent de l'argent
pour que je tue quelqu'un,
soit je les tue.
Très binaire,
comme conception de la vie.
J'aime beaucoup.
On est plutôt
de la 1ère catégorie.
Intéressant !
Pour 5 000 pièces,
je tue qui vous voulez.
On cherche un scientifique.
Y a un scientifique qui est
arrivé y a pas longtemps.
Vous voulez le tuer ?
- Ah non.
- Je comprends pas.
Et vous savez ce que je fais
aux gens que je comprends pas ?
- Vous les tuez ?
- Absolument !
Vous allez goûter à ma hache !
Elle a le goût de la mort !
Non, attendez !
Si, vous avez raison, on veut
le tuer, ce scientifique.
Tu veux tuer ton père ?
Vous vous entendez
si mal que ça ?
Chut, c'est un stratagème.
Il nous mène à lui,
et hop, on se téléporte.
Alors, suivez-moi !
Je sais où le trouver.
Ce sera 6 000 pièces.
6 000 ?
Bah, tout à l'heure, c'était...
Quand on me fait
tourner en bourrique,
le prix augmente.
Sinon, ce bateau est en feu.
On peut peut-être
négocier plus tard.
Voici mon bateau !
En route !
C'est vous qui avez mis
le feu à l'autre bateau ?
- Ouais !
- Pourquoi donc ?
Parce que je suis un pirate !
Je tue tout le monde
et je mets le feu !
Bah, vous pourriez pas
prendre le bateau
et le revendre, plutôt ?
À quoi bon vivre si je peux pas
brûler des bateaux ?
Accrochez-vous,
j'ouvre les voiles.
On n'est pas très loin.
Euh... la Buse ?
J'ai une mission très spéciale
pour vous.
Une mission que seul
un grand pirate peut remplir.
Je suis
le plus grand des pirates !
Vous nous menez
à ce scientifique,
mais vous n'allez pas
le tuer tout de suite.
Vous voulez que je le torture ?
Vous commencez à me plaire !
Non, non, non, non, non,
non, non, vous le tuerez
quand l'un d'entre nous
dira le signal.
Et ce signal, ce sera le mot...
- "Pomme".
- "Pomme" ?
Voilà, "pomme". Facile, hein ?
Vous ne le tuez pas
tant que l'un d'entre nous
n'a pas dit "pomme".
Comme vous voudrez.
J'entends à des lieues
à la ronde.
Je vais pas le louper.
Euh, Eliot, pourquoi "pomme" ?
C'est mon mot de passe interne.
T'es pas super sécurisé.
Personne ne veut pirater
une machine à café.
Meurtre plus signal secret,
ça fera 7 000 pièces.
Direction la taverne !
Je sais pas pourquoi,
mais j'ai l'impression
que tout ça
est un très mauvais plan.
En route !
Le scientifique
vient dans cette taverne
tous les jours
en début de soirée.
On pourra pas le rater.
Tout le monde l'insulte
quand il entre.
Bonsoir,
qu'est-ce que je vous sers ?
Du rhum pour ces gars-là
et pour moi.
De l'eau pour moi.
J'ai assez bu au Moyen Âge.
De l'eau ?
T'as du cran, j'aime ça !
Aïe.
Moi, je vais aux latrines.
Je me retiens depuis 2 jours.
J'aime pas faire caca
sur mon bateau.
Et touchez pas
à mon verre, hein !
Vous savez ce que je fais aux
gens qui touchent à mon verre ?
J'imagine que vous...
Je les tue !
Eh bah voilà,
c'est ce que je pensais.
Et voilà les 3 rhums et...
un verre d'eau
pour l'homme courageux.
Merci.
Iris, c'est fou,
toutes les aventures
qu'on vit ensemble.
On a frôlé la mort,
et c'est dans ces moments-là
qu'on réalise que l'amour...
Mais c'est vrai
qu'on a complètement oublié
de te déposer chez toi !
Je peux le faire immédiatement.
Non, non !
Non, on a une mission !
Je veux rencontrer ton père,
qui est probablement
un grand homme...
Non.
Non, je t'arrête tout de suite.
Mon père n'est pas
un grand homme.
C'est un homme qui a jamais
levé le nez de ses inventions
pour regarder un dessin
que je lui avais fait.
Quand j'étais ado,
je suis partie
une semaine sans le prévenir.
Quand je suis rentrée,
il m'a juste dit :
"T'as passé une bonne soirée ?"
D'accord, bah,
il a quand même inventé
la machine à voyager
dans le temps...
Il a jamais su vivre
le moment présent,
alors je trouve ça un peu lâche
d'essayer d'en partir.
Bah je...
Moi, si tu me faisais un dessin,
je l'accrocherais au frigo,
parce que c'est ça, un couple,
c'est des petites attentions...
Écoutez, là-bas.
Regardez qui que v'là !
C'est le scientifique !
Ça doit être mon père,
allons-y.
Alors, le scientifique ?
Tu scientifises quoi
en ce moment ?
Expliquez-nous votre histoire
de gravitationnalité !
Eh bien, lorsqu'un objet tombe,
en vérité,
il est attiré par la Terre.
Mais c'est pas du tout
mon père.
Identification.
C'est le scientifique
Isaac Newton.
Donc si je te soulève
comme ça...
Ouh là !
Et que je te jette par terre...
Mais je t'ai rien fait,
mon grand !
T'as juste été attiré
par la Terre !
À vrai dire,
vous m'avez projeté au sol,
donc vous avez exercé une force
en plus de celle de la gravité.
Il faudrait plutôt
me soulever...
Ah, vous me portez
à bout de bras
et vous me lâchez.
Intéressant, non ?
Vous n'avez exercé
aucune force de propulsion.
Et pourtant,
j'ai filé droit vers le sol.
C'est la Terre qui m'a attiré.
Les gars,
et si on essayait dans l'eau,
pour voir s'il est attiré
dans le fond ?
Non, ça, c'est Archimède.
On nous confond, parfois.
Allez, on l'emmène au port,
on l'attache à un gros caillou
et on fait une expérience
scientifique !
Si Isaac Newton est là,
c'est forcément
en rapport avec mon père.
Il faut l'aider.
Psst, Monsieur Newton ?
- Oui ?
- Préparez-vous à courir.
Eh, les gars !
Rhum gratuit
pour les 1ers au bar !
Suivez-moi, courez !
C'est bon, nous sommes à l'abri,
dans cette ruelle.
Oh, merci, mes braves.
Faut qu'on se dépêche
avant que la Buse revienne,
parce qu'à votre avis,
il fait quoi aux gens
qui s'enfuient pendant
qu'il est aux toilettes ?
Je sais, il les tue !
C'est ça ?
Bravo, super, Einstein.
Bon, Monsieur Newton,
qu'est-ce que vous faites là ?
Vous vivez pas en Angleterre ?
Si, mais je suis venu ici
pour réfléchir au calme
à une nouvelle théorie,
et prendre un peu de vacances.
Ce sont clairement
les pires vacances de ma vie.
Je suis un grand scientifique
très respecté dans mon pays.
Savez-vous comment
j'ai découvert la théorie
de la gravitation universelle ?
Je marchais sous un arbre,
quand soudain une...
Non, ne dites pas ce mot !
Non, pitié !
La Buse n'est pas loin !
Une poire m'est tombée
sur la tête.
Ouf !
Bah, attendez... une poire ?
Mais dans les livres,
on nous a toujours dit que...
J'ai toujours été passionné
par les sciences,
depuis que je suis haut
comme trois...
Non, non !
Chatons qu'on aurait mis
les uns sur les autres.
Et j'étais très mignon.
Monsieur Newton,
auriez-vous rencontré
un autre scientifique ?
Tout à fait.
Voyez-vous,
un certain Docteur Simon
m'a approché
pour en savoir plus
sur une de mes théories
abandonnées
sur l'infiniment moyen.
Et s'il y avait quelque chose
entre l'infiniment grand
et l'infiniment petit ?
Ce n'est ni petit ni grand,
ni fini ni infini,
ni passé ni présent,
ni mou ni dur,
ni froid ni chaud...
Oui, bon, merci, on a compris.
Tu m'étonnes qu'il ait
abandonné cette théorie.
Mais pourquoi mon père
s'est intéressé à ça ?
Ça m'a fait plaisir
de parler avec quelqu'un
qui me comprenait, mais ensuite,
il m'a volé mon carnet
et il a disparu.
Et il a dit quelque chose,
avant de partir ?
Genre : "Allez, salut,
je vais aller à..."
- Parfaitement.
- OK, cool.
Il a précisé
qu'il partait chez les Mayas
pour y déposer une relique.
- Les Mayas ?
- Une relique ?
Oui, une relique
qui contient une...
Pomme !
Votre Isaac Newton
vient de se faire buter
par la hache de la Buse.
Mais la Buse, t'abuses !
On n'a pas dit le signal !
Si ! Moi, je l'ai dit !
Vous avez dit qu'on le tuait pas
tant qu'un d'entre nous
disait pas "pomme",
j'ai dit "pomme".
C'est logique,
on ne peut pas lui reprocher ça.
- Merci.
- C'est quoi, cette histoire ?
Mon père a déposé une relique
chez les Mayas ?
J'ai la trace d'un passage
du Docteur Simon
dans la civilisation maya
en l'an 1524.
Maintenant, donnez-moi
mes 8 000 pièces !
Vous savez ce que je fais
aux gens qui me payent pas ?
Vous êtes sympa
et vous passez l'éponge ?
Je les tue !
- J'aurai essayé.
- Ah, non, non !
Mais bien sûr, hein,
on va vous payer !
- Bon, alors ? Ça vient ?
- Attendez, ne bougez pas.
Je les cherche,
je les cherche, Eliot...
- Vous les avez ou pas ?
- Retemporalisation dans 5...
- Vous avez pas les pièces ?
- 4... 3... 2... 1...
- Je vais vous tuer !
- On bouge !
Nous voici dans le sud
du Mexique en 1524.
La température extérieure
est très précisément
de 29 degrés centigrades.
La faune sauvage se compose
d'insectes, de lamas...
OK, vous aussi,
ça vous fait un truc bizarre
dans les intestins,
le voyage dans le temps ?
Non, ça, c'est l'eau
que t'as bue dans la taverne.
Et tu pourras pas dire
qu'on t'a pas prévenu.
Bon sang,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
La Buse ?
Il faisait nuit,
et là, il fait jour !
Où qu'on est ?
Par quelle magie ?
Ce sont de nouvelles terres ?
Ça sent le trésor à plein nez !
Préparez mes 8 000 pièces,
je vais piller tout le monde
et je reviens !
Nickel, on vient de lâcher
un pirate sanguinaire
chez les Mayas.
Mais où peut bien être
le Docteur Simon ?
Que va-t-il arriver
à nos héros ?
Et qu'en est-il
de cette drôle de relique ?
Tout ça, je le sais.
Vous aimeriez bien
être à ma place, hein ?
Rendez-vous au prochain épisode
de L'Épopée temporelle.
À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Nos héros sont en terre maya,
au milieu
d'une végétation luxuriante
et dans une chaleur étouffante,
à la recherche
du Docteur Simon
et d'une prétendue relique.
Et comme moult explorateurs
vous le confirmeront,
les aventures à l'étranger
commencent bien souvent
par un problème d'intestins.
Thomas !
- C'est pas moi !
- C'est Eliot, peut-être ?
Je n'ai pas d'orifice
qui permet de produire ce son.
Bon, Thomas,
prends un moment pour toi.
- Nous, on t'attend ici.
- Ça vient pas de moi.
Vous savez quoi ?
Ça m'énerve, ces accusations.
J'ai besoin d'un moment tout
seul pour réfléchir à un plan
pour récupérer
la relique de ton père,
juste
derrière les buissons, là...
Les buissons de la réflexion...
Je reviens.
Iris, c'est étrange.
Je ne t'ai jamais vue
assouvir ce besoin humain
que représente
l'évacuation des déchets.
Ouais, parce que je suis
une princesse, Eliot.
- Tenez, voici les clés.
- Aliénor !
Regarde, Thomas, y a...
Ah, c'est vrai, il fait caca.
Mais vous ne prenez pas
les clés ?
Mais on s'en fout,
de tes clés à la con !
Tu vois bien qu'on n'est plus
enfermés dans un bateau !
Mais j'essaye d'aider,
Dame Iris !
Mais où sommes-nous,
désormais ?
Quelle est
cette forêt luxurieuse ?
Est-ce le paradis ?
Bon, perdons pas de temps,
garde tes clés, là,
et donne-nous la machine
à voyager dans le temps.
Très bien.
Si ça peut me permettre
de récupérer mon royaume...
Mais putain, il faut toujours
qu'elle disparaisse !
- Iris, tu entends ?
- C'est Thomas !
Je détecte
d'autres êtres humains,
certainement des Mayas.
Ne nous approchons pas,
ils sont trop nombreux.
Mais ils sont
en train de l'enlever !
C'est trop dangereux
pour le moment.
On le laisse se faire trucider ?
Non, bien sûr que non !
Pardon, je n'avais pas compris
que le ton induisait la réponse.
- On va à son secours !
- Suivons-les... de loin.
OK... Euh, les gars ?
Vous comptez faire quoi
avec moi, au juste, là ?
Je sens que c'est important,
mais j'ai un peu peur...
Oh, une pyramide !
D'accord, OK,
on va à la pyramide.
Putain, c'est toujours
quand j'ai besoin
d'un traducteur robot du futur
qu'y en jamais.
Vous allez faire quoi de moi ?
Regarde, Iris,
ils emmènent Thomas
en haut de la pyramide.
Oh, merde, un sacrifice humain !
Bon, bah, on le laisse là ?
Non, non, c'est pas possible...
Quoique... Non, non, non !
Eliot, on s'approche,
il faut le sauver.
La cérémonie commence.
Je peux pas regarder.
Je ferme les yeux,
c'est trop cruel !
Ils soulèvent Thomas
devant la foule
et le tendent à bout de bras.
J'ai pas fermé les yeux
pour que tu me décrives
précisément la mort de mon ex !
Très bien.
Mode silencieux activé.
Oh, mon Dieu,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Ils l'ont tué ?
Fin du mode silencieux.
Je décris ou je décris pas ?
Oh, tant pis, j'ouvre les yeux.
Arrêtez !
Arrêtez, non !
Ils le chatouillent ?
Oh, les cons, les cons !
Vous êtes cons, putain !
Ils ont l'air
totalement pacifiques, en fait.
Allons-y, Eliot,
on a peut-être une chance !
D'autres étrangers !
Oh, salut, les amis !
Bienvenue.
Vous voulez des guillis aussi ?
Non, non, non, sans façon.
Nous sommes ici pour libérer
notre ami Thomas.
Il est pas prisonnier,
on devait juste faire
la cérémonie des chatouilles.
Maintenant que c'est fait,
nous avons satisfait les dieux,
et donc...
Chocolat chaud !
Même s'il fait chaud
Il boit son cacao
Et pendant qu'il le touille
On lui fait des chatouilles
Il est trop bon, votre cacao !
Presque aussi bon que mon café.
Je suis preneur de la recette.
Vraiment ?
C'est pas vos traditions, de
faire des sacrifices humains ?
Avant, oui.
Avant, y a 200 ans,
nos ancêtres
étaient complètement fous.
Ils sacrifiaient des vierges
pour les dieux, tout ça.
Mais entre-temps,
on a découvert le cacao.
Ça nous a tous détendus.
Et maintenant, c'est chatouilles
et chocolat chaud !
Aujourd'hui, on est pacifiques.
C'est fini, cette violence.
D'ailleurs, comment peut-on
vous aider, étrangers ?
Je suis un robot
qui vient du futur,
et voici Thomas,
du 20ème siècle.
Nous sommes ici pour chercher
une relique que l'inventeur
de la machine
à voyager dans le temps
vous a sûrement confiée.
Mais non,
fallait pas tout dire comme ça !
- Ah oui, je vois, d'accord.
- Mais... vous nous croyez ?
On croit déjà
une bonne trentaine de dieux,
dont le dieu
chasseur d'opossums.
Alors des gens
qui voyagent dans le temps,
franchement, c'est pas dingue.
Ah, bah, d'ailleurs, on a eu
la visite d'un dieu blanc
pas plus tard que ce matin.
Oh, super, c'est mon père !
Menez-nous à lui.
Non, car il a disparu
comme par magie.
Il nous a donné
une relique à protéger
comme la prunelle de nos yeux.
On l'a enfouie sous le temple
avec des pièges,
des gardes, des caïmans.
On adore les caïmans.
Regardez là-bas,
des nouveaux visiteurs !
Ils arrivent
dans des énormes bateaux !
Préparez du cacao
pour les visiteurs !
Ce qu'ils appellent visiteurs
semblent être
des conquistadors.
Cool !
Ils vont nous massacrer
et s'emparer du pays.
Pas cool.
Waouh, comment ils sont beaux,
les nouveaux visiteurs !
Assis sur leurs chiens géants
et tout !
Oh là là, t'as vu ?
Ils ont des bâtons qui font
du bruit et des éclairs !
Regarde, Capu !
Des cavaliers avec des fusils ?
On est mal, on est mal...
Euh, amis mayas, ces hommes
sont mauvais et dangereux.
Ils sont là pour s'emparer
de vos terres !
Mais non, ça va !
Soyez pas paranos comme ça !
Descendons les accueillir !
Vite, le cacao
et les gaufrettes !
Visiteurs, voici du cacao
et des petites gaufrettes
croustillantes super bonnes.
Tiens, régale-toi.
Hola, soy el capitán Fernández.
Et par ce drapeau,
je déclare ce pays
colonie du royaume d'Espagne !
Hein ?
Eliot, c'est cool,
la traduction,
mais c'est obligé,
l'accent pourri ?
Je n'aime pas cet homme.
Je lui fais un accent pourri.
Emparez-vous de los otros !
- Quoi ?
- Oh, putain !
Mais ça va pas ?
Ligotez les prisonniers
et tuez le reste !
Pas de survivants !
C'est un massacre !
- Adieu, Capu !
- Adieu, Chino !
Attends, vous vous appelez
Capu et Chino ?
Un cappuccino.
Combien de sucres ?
On vous l'avait dit,
ils vous nous massacrer !
Iris, avant de mourir,
je voulais te dire que...
mes sentiments pour toi...
- La Buse ?
- Mais c'est qui, lui ?
- On l'avait oublié !
- Ah, mais on nous aide ?
Ma, ma, ma... Mais...
¿Qué pasa?
On fait de la compote
et du cidre !
Lui, défonce-le !
Non, pas lui, c'est un Maya !
Ah, trop tard, c'est pas grave.
- Vas-y, la Buse !
- Et un dernier, la Buse !
Pas moi,
je suis le capitán Fernández...
- Pitié !
- Tiens ! Prends ça !
Ouais, il nous a sauvés !
- J'adore ce voyage.
- Bien joué, la Buse !
Oh, merci, tu nous as sauvés !
Sans toi, c'était la fin.
C'est bizarre,
ce qui s'est passé.
J'avais ni envie
de vous demander de l'argent,
ni envie de vous tuer,
juste envie de vous aider.
Ah, ça, la Buse,
c'est parce qu'on est devenus
des amis.
Des amis ?
Mais où t'étais, la Buse ?
Oh, mes "des-amis" !
J'ai vécu
une aventure incroyable !
Je suis parti
à la recherche d'un trésor.
- J'ai vu ce temple...
- La pyramide ?
Ouais, ça, je suis entré dedans
et puis j'ai suivi
mon instinct de pirate.
Y avait des énigmes à résoudre,
genre 2 statues
presque identiques
mais qui pouvaient bouger.
Il semble qu'il fallait faire
une combinaison de mouvements.
Ouais, et alors ?
J'ai tout cassé,
puis je suis passé.
Oh non, il a cassé nos pièges !
Après, y avait un long corridor,
il manquait des dalles.
Et y avait
des flèches empoisonnées
qui sortaient des murs.
Il semblait qu'il y avait
un chemin précis à suivre.
Ouais, et alors ?
J'ai tout cassé !
Puis enfin, je suis arrivé
devant une porte
en métal forgé,
avec des tas de chiffres,
On aurait dit
une suite de nombres.
Et t'as tout cassé ?
Non, j'ai remis les chiffres
dans un ordre précis.
C'était la suite de Fibonacci.
Quelqu'un me l'avait expliquée
avant que je le tue.
Mais ça veut dire que t'as
trouvé la relique de mon père !
- Enfin, le trésor !
- Ouais, le v'là.
C'est un truc en bois rond
qui coulisse
avec plein de bidules
écrits dessus, pas dingue.
Oh, je me souviens de ça !
C'était un jouet que j'avais
quand j'étais petite.
C'est un calendrier rond
que mon père m'avait donné
pour apprendre
le système solaire.
Est-ce qu'on s'en irait pas ?
Parce qu'y a les cavaliers
qui débarquent encore.
Eliot, dis-moi qu'il y a
un indice sur cet objet.
D'après mes capteurs,
le calendrier
possède une balise donnant
des coordonnées temporelles
divisées en 3 parties.
Il nous manque 2 balises.
Et où est-ce qu'on trouve ça,
nous ?
Vite, Eliot, les conquistadors
sont plus très loin !
C'est bon.
Mes calculs m'indiquent
où se trouve la seconde balise.
- Yes, Eliot, tu déchires !
- On peut s'y rendre maintenant.
Je viens avec vous,
les des-amis !
La Buse, je pense que ta force
sera plus utile aux Mayas,
qui vont devoir affronter
les conquistadors.
Ouais !
Notre destination
semble très dangereuse.
Une aide puissante
ne serait pas de refus.
Bon d'accord.
La Buse, tu viens avec nous.
Oh...
Coordonnées rentrées.
Mes amis mayas,
je vous cache pas
que les prochaines semaines
risquent d'être difficiles.
Alors tenez bon, OK ?
Vous inquiétez pas.
On va faire
ce qu'on sait faire de mieux.
On fait des guillis
Et ça nous réussit
Les dieux sont ravis
Et on s'fait des amis
OK,
et juste comme ça, hein :
s'ils vous offrent
des couvertures, refusez-les.
- Retemporalisation immédiate.
- Allez, salut !
Le saviez-vous ?
Les envahisseurs européens
n'ont pas hésité à donner
des couvertures contaminées
par la petite vérole
pour décimer
les populations d'Amérique.
L'Épopée temporelle,
ce n'est pas
que du divertissement,
c'est aussi de la culture...
sauf les petites gaufrettes.
Ça, les Mayas,
ils n'en avaient pas.
À la semaine prochaine
pour découvrir
leur nouvelle destination.